بفرض عقوبات على النظام الايراني وتعطيل
شبكات تمويله
البرلمان الصيني ينتخب شيجنبين رئيسا
للبلاد لولايه ثالثه ورئيسا للجنه
العسكريه المركزيه
اسرائيل تعلن الاصابه ثلاثه اشخاص باطلاق
نار في تل ابيب وحماس تتبنى الهجوم
ونتنياهو يصفه بالخطير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر هكذا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن ان
الاداره الامريكيه ستواصل استخدام كل
الادوات المتاحه لديها لتعطيل جهود طهران
في مجال تصنيع المسيرات في تعليقنا على
عقوبات ايران قلب لينكن واشنطن ستواصل
العمل مع الحلفاء وشركاء لمحاسبه ايران
على افعالها المزعزعه للاستقرار
هذا هو فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوباتا على ايران هي الثانيه خلال يومين
شمره العقوبات الجديده تسعه وثلاثين فردا
وكيانا بما فيها عقوبات ضد الكائنات مقرها
الصين وشركات تعمل على تصميم المسيرات
وعقوبات على شبكات مصرفيه تساهم في دخول
مليارات الدولارات على ايران سنويا حسب ما
وردته الوزاره
نشرت شبكه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه تقريرا
يتهم الصين بسرقه اسرار عسكريه امريكيه
مهمه سرقه مكنتها على مر سنوات من صناعه
نسخه صينيه من المقاتل الامريكيه اف 22
الاكثر تطورا في العالم
باقرار امريكي سقطت فخر الجويه الامريكيه
اف 22 عن عرش اقوى جيش في العالم فالتنين
الصيني تمكن من ضمها لاسطوله العسكري
بالسرقه وفقا لشبكه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه
تذكر الشبكه في لقاء اجرته مع جيمس
اندرسون القائم باعمال وكيلي وزاره الدفاع
السابق كيف صبت جهود تجسس الصين المستمره
منذ سنوات في صناعه جيل الخامس من
المقاتلات الجويه مشروع بدات الصين عام
2008 ونجحت في ادخاله الخدمه عام 2017
وفقا لمعلومات سابقه كشفتها السوشيات غير
ان السؤال الذي يتبادر الى الاذهان هو كيف
تمكنت الصين من الحصول على معلومات شديده
السريه والحساسيه من داخل البرتغون
يجيب اندرسون ان الصين لجات اولا الى
الطرق الكلاسيكيه تجنيد واستماله متعاقدين
امريكيين واكاديميين وموظفين حكوميين
للحصول على بيانات اساسيه حول البرامج
والانظمه العسكريه ثانيا استخدام اساليب
اكثر تقدما مثل النشاط السيبراني لاختراق
قاعده بيانات وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
والاهم نشروا اجهزه تجسس متطوره قادره على
جمع معلومات تمكنها من الحصول على الملفات
السريه وتحديد اماكن وجودها
لسنوات ظل دافع الصين لفهم المحركات
النفاثه الاكثر تطورا في الغرب حافزا
لمهمات تطوير عمليات التجسس لسد فجوه
عسكريه لطالما سعت واشنطن لابقائها ضمن
حدود تفوقها العسكري
اساليب التجسس الصينيه جعلتهم يقلصون فجوه
مدتها 30 عاما الى عشره اعوام فقط بيننا
وبينهم في تكنولوجيا المحركات النفاثه
ورغم تطابق الشكل الخارجي للمقاتله
الصينيه مع نظيرتها الامريكيه الا انه لا
يزال من الصعب تحديد مدى كفاءه جي 20
مقارنه بf22 لكن استمرار تزايد التوتر بين
البلدين في ظل مناقشه غزو محتمل والذي قد
يشمل ردا عسكريا امريكيا سيكون ساحه مهمه
لكشف حقيقه المقاتله الصينيه بلا شك مكرم
حناوي العربيه
اعلنت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان الدول
المشاركه في الاليه الاوروبيه للتسويه
الماليه مع ايران قررت ايقاف التعامل بها
في وقت تصاعدت فيه التوترات بين الغرب
وايران جراء قمع المتظاهرين اضافه لتزويد
روسيا بطائرات بدون طيار في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الخارجيه الالمانيه قالت في
بيان الله ان قررت دول الاوروبيه بحل هذه
الاليه ياتي جراء الاعاقه المنظمه لعملها
من قبل ايران
اجمل مواطن الامريكي اماكن مازل المعتقل
في سجن ايفين بايران بتهمه التجسس مقابله
نادره عبر الهاتف مع محطه سي ان طلب فيها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بالتدخل لاطلاق
سراحه الى جانب مواطنين امريكيين اخرين
المنزل المعتقل منذ سبعه اعوام ونصف العام
نشد بايدن ان يضع حياه وحريه الامريكيين
الابرياء فوق كل السياسات وان يفعل ما هو
ضروري لانهاء ما وصفه بالكابوس الذي
يعيشونه داخل السجن واعادتهم الى الوطن
نظمت المعارضه الايرانيه في واشنطن مؤتمرا
في مجلس النواب للاعلان عن تاييد نواب من
الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري لقرار يطالب
واشنطن بنهج جديد للتعامل مع انتهاكات
طهران ضد المحتجين والمراه ويحاسبها على
العمليات الارهابيه التي ترعى
[تصفيق]
لا متزايد في مجلس النواب الامريكي لتبني
نهج امريكي جديد للتعامل مع ايران في ضوء
استمرار انتهاكات النظام ضد الشعب
الايراني اكثر من 220 نائبا من الحزبين
ايدوا قرارا يدعم الشعب الايراني ويعترفوا
بحقه باقامه نظام ديمقراطيه ويدين مواسطه
بالقتل الوحشي للمتظاهرين
سوف يسمع الرئيس صوت الكونغرس وامنوا ان
يقف معنا غالبا ما يريد التفاوض مع حكومه
ايران وهذا خطا بالنسبه لي لانهم لا
يتفاوضون بحسن نيه لذلك امل ان يسمع صوتنا
باننا نعارض النظام الذي يريد ديمقراطيه
وحريه وايران غير نوويه تعيش في سلام مع
جيرانها
القرار يدين ايضا ووصفها بالهجمات
الارهابيه التي يرعاها النظام الايراني ضد
مواطني الولايات المتحده ومسؤوليها وكذلك
المعارضين الايرانيين
هذا القرار مهم لانه في اول 50 يوما من
الكونجرس الجديد
لقدميات 225 عضوا في الكونجرس ديمقراطيون
وجمهوريون من اجل ايران حره ومن اجل
جمهوريه ايران ايران
نجحت المعارضه الايرانيه من حشد تاييد
كبير لهذا القرار من خلال ناخذها
الامريكيين من اصل الايرانيه في مختلف
الولايات وهو ما بدا واضحا من دعم الحزبين
له في مجلس النواب
الدور القيادي للنساء الايرانيات في
الانتفاضه الحاليه لقى ايضا تاييدا خاصه
في ظل تطور قضيه الهجمات السامه على مدارس
الفتيات والتي تتهم الحكومه الايرانيه
بالوقوف خلفها
من المحزن ان نسمع عن التسمم وهو غريب
للغايه ولكن للاسف هذا نتيجه نظام
استبدادي وسيكون من الصعب تحديد المسؤول
عما حدث في ظل نظام يعيش بحكم السلاح لكن
خلاصه القول هي ان النساء يتعرضن للهجوم
وطريقه الحل هي العمل على الترويج لنظام
الديمقراطي
وفي سياق المسار الجديد يدعو القرار
الحكومه الامريكيه للعمل مع حلفائها
الاوروبيين لمحاسبه طهران على انتهاك
الامتيازات الدبلوماسيه ودعوه الدولي الى
منع الانشطه الخبيثه للبعثه الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيه بهدف اغلاقها وترضي وكلائها
حسين الطاوض العربيه واشنطن
رحبت واشنطن باعلان الامم المتحده توقيعات
اتفاق لشراء ناقله واستخدامها في تفريغ
مليون ومئه الف برميل نفط في خزان او من
خزان صافر العائم قباله اليمن وقالت
الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان شراء ناقله
لتفريغ خزان سافر يعتبر خطوه حاسمه في
تنفيذ خطه الطوارئ التي وضعتها الامم
المتحده لتجنب كارثه بيئيه اقليميه في
البحر الاحمر واثار اقتصاديه يكون لها
تداعيات عالميه مع تفاقم اسوا ازمه
انسانيه في العالم
انتخب البرلمان الصيني الرئيس شيجنبنغ
للمره الثالثه رئيسا للبلاد لفتره
الرئاسيه مدتها خمس سنوات ليحكم قبضته على
السلطه كاقوى زعيم يحكم البلاد منذ
وصوت البرلمان الصيني المؤلف من قرابه
3000 عضو بالاجماع في قاعه الشعب الكبرى
بالعاصمه على انتخاب الشيليراس البلاد في
انتخابات خلت من اي مرشح اخر
اكدت الشرطه الاسرائيليه اصابه ثلاثه
اشخاص خلال عمليه اطلاق نار في تل ابيب
فيما وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو الهجوم الذي وقع في تل ابيب
بالخطير حيث فتح شخص النار على مجموعه من
الاشخاص عند مقهى في شارع احد شوارع تل
ابيب وقالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه انها قتلت
المنفذ فيما افاد مراسل العربيه انه من
الضفه الغربيه وعمره 23 عاما واعلنت حركه
حماس ان منفذ اطلاق النار في تل ابيب هو
احد اعضائه
الفجوات بين الائتلاف والمعارضه بشكل كبير
هناك اتفاقات بخصوص معظم القضايا ليس كلها
لكن غالبيتها ان مقترح القانون الذي تجري
مناقشته حاليا يجب التخلي عنه وبسرعه انه
خاطئ انه عدواني ويقوض اسس النمقراطيه
لذلك يجب استبداله على الفور واحلال خطه
مختلفه متفق عليها للمناقشه
تسع اوكرانيا مدعومه من عدد من دول اوروبا
والمفوضيه الاوروبيه الى انشاء محكمه خاصه
لمقادات لمقاضات روسيا يتولى جمع الادله
والبيانات حول جرائم الحرب اعضاها
المساعي الاوروبيه لانشاء محكمه خاصه
لمقاضاه عدوان روسيا على اوكرانيا حسب
العبارات الرسميه الاوروبيه
قطعت خطوه اضافيه في هذا الاتجاه من خلال
انشاء المركز الدولي للتحقيق في جريمه
العدوان في مدينه الفيفا الاوكرانيه نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي
المركز سيحتضنهم مؤقتا مكتب الادعاء
الاوروبي في لوكسمبور ويتولد تحقيق وجمع
الادله وانشاء البيانات حول جرائم
المرتكبه
قطعنا المرحله الاولى المتمثله في المركز
الدولي للتحقيق في جريمه العدوان الهدف
يظل البحث عن الهيئه القضائيه المناسبه
منها خيار المحكمه الخاصه مثل ما طلبت
اوكرانيا او اي صيغه اخرى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لا تمتلك صلاحيه التحقيق
في جريمه العدوان لان روسيا واوكرانيا
كلتيهما ليست طرفا في محكمه لاهاي علاوه
على عضيه روسيا الدائمه في مجلس الامن
المحكمه الدوليه تحقق فقط في جرائم الحرب
والجرائم ضد الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
المساعي الاوروبيه تتجه اذا نحو انشاء
محكمه خاصه حول العدوان على اوكرانيا
لانشاء المحكمه الخاصه حول اوكرانيا اذا
حظي المشروع بدعم الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لكن قرارات الجمعيه العامه ليست
ملزمه ولا تمتلك الامم المتحده صلاحيه
الزام روسيا بالتعاون مع هذه المحكمه دوله
روسيا قياداتها مؤسساتها تتمتع بحصانه
الدوله ولا يمكن لاي محكمه فرض ارادتها
عليها
كما لا يمكن للمحكمه المزمعه محاكمه
قيادات روسيا غيابيا ما يدعو للشك في جدول
المساعي الجاريه الى تشكيلها مشروع اقامه
المحكمه الخاصه لمقضاه روسيا احدث شرخا
كبيرا في صفوف خبراء القانون الدولي
وافتراض اقامه هاته المحكمه الخاصه حول
اوكرانيا سيعزز الشعور بازدواجيه المعايير
في تطبيق القانون الدولي
احتلالات العراق وافغانستان وفلسطين لا
تزال دون محاسبه
نور الدين الفريد العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
الرئيس التونسي يصدر مرسوما بحل جميع
المجالس البلديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قتل سبعه اشخاص واصيب
ثمانيه اخرون بجروح خطيره جراء اطلاق نار
ليل الخميس في كنيسه لشهود في شمال
هامبورج ورجحت الشرطه ان يكون مطلق النار
من بين القتلى الذين سقطوا في الموقع
مشيره الى انه ليس لديها ما يشير الى وجود
منفذين هاربين وفي وقت لا يزال الدافع
وراء اطلاق النار مجهولا حتى الان
اصدر الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مرسوما بحل
جميع المجالس البلديه الى حين انتخابي
مجالس جديده وفي المرسوم الذي نشرته
الجريده الرسميه اقر الرئيس التونسي
مرسوما يتعلق بانتخابات المجالس المحليه
وتشكيل المجالس الجهويه ومجالس الاقاليم
ودعاء اعضاء مجلس النواب لحضور الجلسه
العامه الافتتاحيه في الثالث عشر من مارس
في جورجيا اثار قانون العملاء الى الجانب
الذي سحبته الحكومه اثار جردلا واسعا في
البلاد حيث ادى الى احتجاجات كبيره في
اوساط المعارضه
جورجيا ساحه صراع جديده بين روسيا والغرب
والسبب قانون العملاء الاجانب الذي اثار
احتجاجات كبيره في هذا البلد المنقسم بين
روسيا والغرب القانون المثير للجدل الذي
يرى المتظاهرون بانهم امتداد للسياسه
روسيا التي لطالما حاولت فرض سيطرتها
بطريقه غير مباشره على البلاد مثل ما
تفعله الان مع اوكرانيا ينص على ان
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ووسائل الاعلام
التي تتلقى اكثر من 20% من تمويلها من
الخارج ملزمه بالتسجيل على انهم عملاء
اجانب تحت طائله الغرامه كما خلف القانون
ازمه سياسيه تنظر بانقسام في السلطه وصراع
داخلي في حزب الحلم الجورجي وايضا تململا
واستياء كبيرين في اوساط المتظاهرين
الغاضبين اصلا من دعم موسكو الانفصاليين
جورجيين بعض النواب في بالحاكم ممن يدعمون
موسكو وفقوا على هذا القانون الذي يغذي
صراع النفوذ بين روسيا ودول الغرب غير ان
رئيسه البلد وقفت مع المتظاهرين الرافدين
لحل المشاكل على الطريقه الروسيه المعارضه
تعتبر ان القانون يذكر بتشريع روسي
يستخدمه الكريم لقمع الصحافه المستقله
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان وخصومه
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات
مسؤول التشريع في الاتحاد الروسي اتهم
بروكسيل و واشنطن بتنفيذ انقلاب غير
دستوري في جورجيا بدعمها للمتظاهرين موجها
اصابع الاتهام لبعض وسائل الاعلام
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه بالولاء لامريكا
غير ان رد واشنطن جاء مؤيدا للمتظاهرين
الرافدين لهذا القانون الذي يمكن ان تتبخر
معه كل مساعي الحكومه في توطيد علاقاتها
مع دول الغرب خصوصا الولايات المتحده
بعد هجوم الانتحاري استهدف مكتب حاكم
ولايه مزار شريف عاصمه ولايه بلغ شمال
افغانستان شبهات تدور حول داعش خرسان
وتقارير استخبارتي تحذر حركه طالبان من
تمدد التنظيم في شرق البلاد
في هجوم انتحاري استهدف مكتبه في مدينه
مزار شريف عاصمه شمال افغانستان يعتقد ان
من يقف خلفه تنظيم داعش خرسان قتل حاكم
ولايه بلخ داوود مزمل واثنان من مرافقيه
وتعود تفاصيل العمليه الانتحاريه الى دخول
شخص يعمل في مقر ولايه وهو يرتدي ستره
مليئه بمواد متفجره فجر نفسه في المبنى
كانت هناك مخاوف من ان العمليه تستهدف
نائب رئيس الوزراء للشؤون الاقتصاديه مولى
عبد الغني برادر الذي كان موجودا سابقا في
المبنى لكنه لم يكن هناك وقت التفجير حركه
طالبان ياتي على راسها الملهبه طل اخزاده
وهو زعيمها ومن حيث القوه ياتي بعده الملا
عبد الغني برادر الذي كان نائبه السابق
واصبح نائبا لرئيس الوزراء بعد سيطره
طالبان على افغانستان اما رئيس الوزراء
الملا محمد حسن اخوند الذي تولى كونه رئيس
شورى الحركه تنظيم داعش خراسان ظهر في
يناير عام 2015 في ولايه ننجهار شرقي
افغانستان وهو يتكون من قيادات ومقاتلين
من حركه طالبان الافغانيه وطالبان
الباكستانيه وكانت اماكن وجود التنظيم في
الولايات الشرقيه لافغانستان
وفي اعقاب سيطره طالبان على البلاد قام
التنظيم بتغيير استراتيجيته بالانتقال الى
الولايات الشماليه خاصه في بدخشان وتخار
وقندوز وبلخا نظرا لضعف سيطره طالبان
عليها وحتى في العاصمه كابل والتي توجد
فيها قيادات التنظيم قوه داعش في
افغانستان تقدر بثلاثه الاف عنصر وفق
تقرير للامم المتحده الا ان منظمه معاهده
الامن الجماعي قدرت عددهم بضعف هذا
العددتنا على معرفه يحدث في افغانستان منذ
سقوط الحكومه لكن لا تزال لدينا بعض
القدره على ذلك وبناء على ما نعرفه بشان
تهديد القاعده هم يحاولون النجاح ولا خطط
لديهم للهجوم على الغرب قريبا نعتقد ان
تنظيم داعش هناك يشكل تهديدا اكبر هم
يتعرضون للهجوم من نظام طالبان الان وهي
مساله وقت قبل ان يكون لديه القدره على
مهاجمتنا
وفي تقرير الاستخباراتي حذر الطالبان من
ان داعش يخطط للدخول الى شرق افغانستان
لتكون قاعده انطلاقهم لباقي البلاد
في نهايه مشاهده تذكيرهم بابرزه عناوينها
يؤكد التزامه واشنطن بفرض عقوبات على
النظام الايراني وتعطيل شبكات تمويله
البرلمان الصيني ينتخب شيجن بنج رئيسا
للبلاد لولايه ثالثه ورئيسا للجنه
العسكريه المركزيه
اسرائيل تعلن اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص باطلاق
نار في تل ابيب حماس تتبنى الهجوم
ونتينياهو يصفه بالخطير
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]